welcome to Hannity we start tonight with
a Fox News Alert the left's favorite
conspiracy theory is now dead it is
buried and there was no collusion no
conspiracy no obstruction nothing the
witch hunt is over and there will be no
further charges no further indictments
after 675 days and nine months before
that with the FBI investigation in other
words almost three years total of an
intensive variant investigation
Robert Mulder's report has officially
been submitted to the Attorney General
of the United States President Trump no
more indictments no collusion charges
will be filed no obstruction charges
will be filed and no conspiracy charges
nor will they be filed congressman mark
meadows put it very well the Muller
report delivery suggests that no more
indictments are coming which we now know
is true from the special counsel and
that means that we just completed two
years of investigating Russia collusion
without one collusion related indictment
not even one instead after nearly two
years tens of millions of your tax
dollars the Muller witch-hunt only
managed to prosecute Oh a few people for
processed crimes let's see Papadopoulos
is big 12 days in jail lying to
prosecutors military hero Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn is not has not
been sentenced he nearly went bankrupt
had to sell his home because of mounting
legal bills with both McCabe and Comey
the FBI director deputy director
admitting and bragging they set him up
something they'd never do in the Obama
or Clinton administration's and we have
Roger stone he's going bankrupt facing
trial for allegedly lying to Congress
and harassing a witness Michael Cohen of
course we know his case pleading guilty
to lie into Congress other crimes
related to taxicab medallions and Bank
application fraud in taxes and Paul
Manafort oh he may spend the rest of his
life in prison because of taxes and
again lying on bank loan applications
what do they all have in common nothing
zero to do with Trump the campaign
Russia or collusion a mother also
indicated dozens of Russian actually
indicted in this case Russian nationals
they're never coming here they're never
going to be extradited many were Russian
spies or Russian bot companies that will
never ever face trial or be extradited
to the United States Putin the bad actor
he is Russian the bad nation they're
never going to allow that to happen
none of these charges involve campaign
collusion whatsoever but we had plenty
of pre-dawn raids and guns drawn and
doors ticked down in the middle of the
night SWAT gear hours and hours of
hardcore interrogation screws turn lives
ruined the money spent for what Trump
Russia collusion was as we always said a
hoax a lie conceived by hate driven by
fear a 22-month witch-hunt
not into a crime but into an individual
a person that's Donald Trump who became
president and everyone around him this
is not how it's supposed to work in this
country this cannot happen again this is
pretty downright despicable and when you
look at our Constitution rule of law
application or equal application of our
laws equal justice under the law every
American tonight should be outraged
concerned about how did we get here
especially now that we have evidence of
known crimes masses abuse of power which
will be the focus of us in days and
months going forward now if the full
weight of America's justice system can
be used to persecute a sitting president
of the United States when they even
tried to set the election up for the
person that they loved when that person
should have been indicted
that would mean nobody in America is
safe and still as the Attorney General
points out the Muller investigation it
was not hindered in any way not by the
president not by anybody as if being
president isn't hard enough the
president well he was forced to deal
with this undue burden of what is a
baseless absurd investigation that all
began before
became president in July of 2016 now
this of course is the mainstream media
spread a constant steady stream of lies
and misinformation to the entire world
about America's sitting president small
reminder oh and this will get big as the
days unfold
take a look you told The Washington Post
last week that quote there's a smell of
treason in the air when it comes to this
investigation we are looking at the
possibility that the President of the
United States and those around him
during an election campaign colluded
with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
Donald Trump now sits at the threshold
of impeachment
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question that what he is doing is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy it
does look like collusion it does look
like he's listening to Putin more than
he has American intelligence and frankly
I've never seen that before
Vladimir Putin and his associates
somebody has something on Donald Trump
we're hearing a new word right he said
it was treason and you wonder why I
called them the hate Trump media mob of
course they hate Trump media mob they
were just following their orders as they
always do from their
leftist Democratic friends taking their
cue from the leaders in the Democratic
Party we have the evidence of that as
well take a look you believe that the
Trump campaign colluded with the
Russians in the 2016 campaign yes do you
believe the President himself colluded
with the Russians yes he colluded and I
don't think that's a far answer
questions I'll certainly say with
confidence that there is significant
evidence of collusion between the
campaign and Russia it's beyond the
shadow of a doubt to me that if there
was not collusion there was at least the
effort to collude with a foreign power
we saw cold hard evidence of the Trump
campaign indeed the Trump family eagerly
intending to collude possibly with
Russia a hostile foreign power to
influence American elections it's
becoming clear we have suffered a
desecration of our democracy Nazi
since Watergate they swallowed it all
hook line and sinker and tonight the
only people actually shocked that the
which hyung came up empty are those on
the Left who again once again rush to
judgment denied due process peddling a
steady stream of daily lies propaganda
misinformation and of course conspiracy
theories and this includes those who
hated Trump so much that they were
willing to suspend any and all logic and
believe in a fantasy and thereby
creating false hopes for every Trump
hater all across the country there will
be a reckoning we will hold all of these
people in the days weeks of months
accountable now of course this includes
known liar and leaker yep congressman
well we call him the Cowardly Schiff he
won't come on this program now he might
be the most attached from reality after
a nine month investigation from the FBI
a 22 month investigation from Muller you
had a bipartisan investigation from the
Senate another bipartisan investigation
in the house after all these
investigations prior to today turned up
zero evidence of collusion nothing well
earlier today Adam Schiff he vowed to
continue his own personal witch-hunt
into the president of course why serve
the American people when you could stay
focused on a conspiracy theory
take a look what are the outstanding
questions are your committee the House
Intelligence Committee for example will
continue to investigate regardless of
what the other Muller report reveals
either there are any of them of examples
that I could give you of information
that we've obtained our investigation
information that's become clear from the
Special Counsel investigation that may
not be neatly summed up in a decision or
disclosure that we decided to indict a
but not B if they're not answered then
we're going to have to answer them we're
going to find the truth chef's continues
to be blinded by his rage and hatred of
all things Trump lying to his
constituents for political gain oh and
of course he's raising money off of
yours truly
sends out fundraising letters with Sean
Hannity attack ship but he's never
backing down please donate here now
either way many in the mainstream media
or the media Bob as we call them they're
starting to face some reality their
favorite conspiracy theory is officially
dead
sad day there's no thrill up people's
legs today over at some other networks
take a look would it be the smoking gun
would it give information as to
criminality what it actually the core
question of collusion to the extent that
it doesn't to the extent that there are
no more indictments I have to say I
think it's good news for the White House
well that's pretty specific this is
really good news a lot of people around
Donald Trump that narrative that this
was all an elaborate setup that that
there was an elaborate piece of the
puzzle waiting for that last element
which was Americans colluding with
Russians it clearly is not part of the
special council's move forward I've been
vindicated by them and then he's now
vindicated exactly if I'm at mar-a-lago
with the president as Pamela has been
reporting the lawyers are feeling good
that that that I would be I would be
very happy you have to say that if it
turns out that there is no indictment
that alleges any conspiracy between
anyone in the Trump campaign and the
Russians that vindicates the president
to some degree you'd see their
disappointment oh it's got to be killing
them I can almost taste their tears from
here years and years of breathless
hysteria lies presented as facts and
truth what is like Maddow and all the
other MSNBC conspiracy theorists what
are they gonna what are they gonna cover
now what does fake News CNN where do
they find their content now Oh a little
Chuckie Todd at night be dreaming of now
I'm sure per usual they'll just find
other fake anti-trump conspiracies to
push all while never apologizing for
outright lies breathless hysterical
coverage day after day night after night
we've been right all along the president
has been vindicated and but so much
damage has already been done we now have
our partisan two-tiered system of
justice that we've been warning you
about it has now been laid bare
for the country in the world to see we
have watched constitutional rights
trampled on the Constitution shredded
the rule of law equal justice under the
law equal application of our laws
frankly is as of today a joke one that
will have a long-standing impact on this
country and our future and the big big
question tonight is where do we go from
here what about all the laws that we
know have been broken with real evidence
but this up until now many Democrats all
these deep state operatives that have
abused power and conspired against Trump
and been involved in conspiracies yeah
they've gotten a free pass Muller spent
22 months investigating President Trump
over what was a fantasy based on no
evidence meanwhile we have for two years
on this program presented real actual
rusick Russian campaign collusion in the
2016 election the biggest abuse of power
scandal in history we have real
collusion with real evidence Hillary
Clinton's dirty Russian dossier was
literally put together by a foreign spy
Christopher steel he used real Russia
lies and from Russia and why was that
not investigated why are we not talking
about that tonight
that dirty Clinton Russian dossier which
was never verified and we now know
unverifiable because it's author he
can't stand by his own dossier his own
writings that same dossier used to
obtain a FISA warrant to spy on a trump
campaign associate and we now know
reporters were fed and spread those
Russian lies and they were spreading it
to the American people before the 2016
election that includes the Washington
Post David corn and Michael Isikoff we
know FISA Court judges that they were
lied to frauds committed before them
they were never told about the dossiers
author hating Trump they were never told
about the hyper partisan nature Hillary
Clinton paid for it they were never told
that none of this was verified or
corroborated never told any of the
why was Carter page in the middle of all
of this why were his constitutional
rights allowed to be violated
based on Hillary Clinton bought and paid
for Russian lies
why was the Trump campaign spied on
because of Clinton bought and paid for
Russian lies why is none of this why
hasn't that not been investigated
where's the special counsel for that and
also we now know thanks to the hills
John Sullivan we know a high-ranking
Ukrainian official tried to help Hillary
Clinton get elected interfere in our
election they did it by timing the
release of embarrassing material about
then campaign chairman Paul Matta for it
a ukrainian court called it an illegal
intrusion into the american election
campaign why was that not investigated
by Muller what about the Iranian one
scandal what about the whole issue of
Vladimir Putin having thugs right here
in America that we know were involved in
bribery extortion kickbacks money
laundering why did we know because we
had an American FBI spy inside of
Putin's Network telling our top law
enforcement Putin wanted a foothold in
the uranium market in America and he got
it because people like Hillary Clinton
and others signed off on that ridiculous
move we don't have enough uranium we
need to import uranium the foundational
material for nuclear weapons what about
the Clinton Foundation oh they ended up
taking about a hundred and forty five
million dollars from all those
executives involved in that uranium one
deal that was Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton signing off on it her husband
meeting with Vladimir Putin three times
as normal speaking fee in Russia why was
that not investigated why were there
when you think about this
no criminal referrals for those
associated with Clinton oh that's right
none of that was investigated because
the special counsels investigation was a
partisan witch hunt from day one
remember after all Muller hired a team
filled with big time Clinton Obama
loving Trump hating Democratic donors
his top lawyer jeanne ray literally
Hillary Clinton's lawyer at the Clinton
Foundation how in good conscience did
she ever get hired by Muller
why was Muller
pitbull is top prosecutor Andrew
Weissman a guy attended Hillary
Clinton's election night victory party
that never transpired he was the top
investigator for Muller from the very
beginning of the investigation
and don't forget Peter struck he was
involved from the get-go you know Peter
struck had a girlfriend Lisa Paige
struck was the one that was calling
Trump supporters smelly Walmart shoppers
saying that Hillary Clinton should win a
hundred million to zero he referred to
Trump as a deplorable human being
loathsome he saw the Russia probe as an
insurance policy to stop Trump in case
he wins and don't forget how they rigged
he was the one that interviewed Hillary
Clinton in her investigation and he was
writing Hillary's exoneration in May of
2016 before they did the investigation
in July and he interviewed Hillary July
2nd Comey exonerated her on July 5th and
then they started investigating Donald
Trump and what about the biggest slam
dunk obstruction of justice case ever
even Alan Dershowitz couldn't get me off
I asked them last night if I had
subpoenaed 33,000 emails I delete them i
acid wash my harddrive with bleach spit
and then I bust up my devices my my
BlackBerry's my iPhones with hammers and
remove SIM cards I think I'd be in jail
for a long time don't forget we had
classified and top-secret information on
Hillary's secret server
what about Muller's other investigators
other prosecutors how many of them they
donate tens and tens of thousands of
dollars to Democrats yeah including
Hillary and Muller hired zero zip
registered Republicans so we're gonna
find out maybe over the weekend maybe
next week sometime soon
this Muller report is inevitably at
least the contents of it to the extent
that we are allowed to the extent the
Attorney General decides it is in his
discretion in his discretion only we're
gonna find out as much as we possibly
can about what's in there but know this
this is only whatever it is it's only
one side of the story whatever you hear
is only the prosecutorial viewpoint from
what is a group of hyper-partisan Trump
haters those who are always held vent on
bludgeoning this president no matter
what but facts matter truth matters and
tonight as pointed out by Byron York
we know that Muller did not indict
Donald Trump jr. or Jared Kushner or
other people's subject to the insane
media hysteria speculation the media
ever going to apologize to them don't
hold your breath and we know that Muller
did not charge anyone in the Trump
campaign nobody and will not be charging
anyone further with conspiring with
Russia to fix the 2016 election we know
that Robert Muller never subpoenaed the
president we know that President Trump
did not fire Muller we know as many
predicted he would we know that the
president did not interfere tonight with
the Muller investigation this was an
investigation into collusion if there's
no collusion obstruction or conspiracy
that was found nothing else matters no
matter what these people that have been
selling you lies for years tell you but
we must never forget what has happened
here a partisan witch hunt that was
designed to protect their favorite
presidential candidate rigged that
election when she should have been
indicted they didn't want Donald Trump
to win so then they lie it and committed
fraud before a FISA Court denying a
fellow citizen their constitutional
rights
spying on an opposition party candidate
in an election year having it leaked to
the American people Russian lies to
influence the election and then of
course telling Donald Trump James Comey
did it well he signs on to the FISA
application in October 2016 in January
2017 he said it's unverified it's
salacious that's not what he told the
FISA Court they never told the FISA
Court that Hillary paid for it they
never told the FISA Court Christopher
steel hated Trump they never told the
FISA Court that nothing's verified here
this cannot happen if we want to remain
a constitutional republic we must bring
the real perpetrators of real fraud real
conspiracy real abuse of power and
corruption to justice where we go from
here tonight matter
all of those who abuse their powers all
of those that did everything in their
power that we grant them we give to them
to first stop Donald Trump from ever
being elected and then having an
insurance policy if he was elected
thinking they knew better than you we
the American people they thought they
knew better than all of us they all need
to be held accountable as we move
forward from this day on in the days the
weeks the months ahead and by the way
you and the media I promise you you will
be eating your fake news conspiracy
theories and reports and hysteria for
decades to come